talking about viva la bam and jackass
yeah so
how much in contact are you with bam
these days
not much at all which is just out to him
like a week ago or two weeks ago and and
there was the first time i hadn't i
actually didn't hear back which is a
good thing yeah right now knowing where
he's at in the position he's in no news
is good news and and i know uh
that he was at a position in his journey
with his recovery that he could have a
phone briefly he kind of earned that and
then i think he's allowed to have a
phone right now and he's just choosing
to not use it which is the best [ __ ]
sign i wish that was the
case that would you're right it's like
[ __ ] there's a sign of hope here is he
out and about or is he interesting so he
they he had the phone and because he
wasn't doing what should be done they
took the phone back from him got it so
that's why i didn't hear about it yeah
totally all right yeah so yeah he's in a
program um and
the good thing is now is is uh he's got
like he's under a conservatorship you
know and it's not a conservative ship
it's a guardianship oh really the
conservatorship britney spears
has financial implications with the
conservatorship they're they're in
charge of all of your your money and
everything a guardianship
they kind of leave your money out of it
yeah and uh and the guardianship they're
just like kind of
there's rules you have to abide by and
he's like forced to be and how how long
do you have to be like that for i think
that i mean i don't know that we're
really even allowed to talk about about
it too much but um
as i understand it it's like uh
still happening yeah yeah really we'll
leave it at that
and the good thing is is
it's kind of doing for him what he
can't do for himself
right i know i agree i agree very much
and um you know it's like even bringing
up bam is just like a
lightning rod of uh
you know like controversy it really is
it's a shame what i want to say is that
i and i've said this before but i'll say
it again is that i've always
not always i used to always
be so jealous of him he was such a
[ __ ]
just ambitious [ __ ] like
just talented
like
he was so good at making footage so
funny and like not it just making great
amazing footage out of like nothing even
happening and i was like man for me to
get footage i got to like
do something huge you know like i
couldn't just make footage out of
nothing like that all you had to do was
get a [ __ ]
dog that's like an idiot that's right
i know but like and i would always say
bam's younger than me he's richer than
me he's like he's better looking than me
he's more talented than me like you know
like and all of that was true
and um i just i i
now with everything going on like i wish
that
we could have the band back who i was
always so jealous of i i would love
to
be jealous of him again and and and i
want that for him i want isn't it crazy
how the world works and kind of goes
full circle you know how you would now
give anything to have that guy back that
at one point in time you're very jealous
of well yeah i mean i i see what you're
saying but it's right and when i say
jealous i think that the that's just my
natural
reaction to being impressed by somebody
you know like when i go to the circus
i'm [ __ ] jealous as hell of the
performers because i want to be that rad
one and and that's why you are that rad
dude this is [ __ ] stevo's wild ride
tour here [ __ ] [ __ ] come and i'm
sober
but no i i
i have credit he's my best friend in the
world um if it wasn't for him i'd be
buried in that plot that my mother
bought me in baltimore like he was the
one that that stopped what he was doing
and reached out to me and said yo
come to westchester live with me like
skate again and wasn't that like a super
misguided exercise and enabling you and
the in the big picture and he brought
you like
he brought you the enough fame and
recognition for you to just
keep staying sick but i don't believe
that he could comprehend right of course
what was going on of course i thought he
was helping you but he was doing knowing
what i know now yes it was like a
terrible recipe for [ __ ] disaster
right and you were just this weird
whipping boy for him
but if you look at this if you weigh out
the scales of justice it's it's that in
that world or like being homeless
shooting up bleach in baltimore
so it's like
right
and and then he had at his house like a
garage that was just filled with like
bam skateboards and you would just go
and oh yeah go for that yeah
like like when you're on dead tour
except
that it was it wasn't mine
your town wasn't sending me those boards
yeah right and and it wasn't dead or it
was the the crack house yeah
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude